Let's go over to Kyiv there.
And, Melissa, security
assistance is going to be coming
where it goes.
It's going to make a big difference here
because it could be compromised
in at least one key area.
There's a critical bridge
that last remaining
supply route
in and out of the city of Bakhmut
was blown up
That's right.
Incredibly difficult
now, Bianna, for Ukrainian forces
to resupply their men
that are still in the center of town.
They tell us it
is, though, a matter of time.
What we heard from one soldier
today is that it could take two
days, could take 20 days.
The question is how long
they can hold out
in the face of these
ever more experienced foreign mercenaries
and Russian troops
that have been flooding in
in a determined effort
to take the home of Obama
with huge questions.
Be on, of course, about the four
and a half thousand civilians
still trapped inside
and there have been
those pleas over the last few weeks
on the part of the Ukrainian military
for more ammunition.
There will be a retreat
at some point westwards.
But what we're seeing
also right now,
even as the fate of Obama
that hangs in
the balance, is further along
that front line to the south.
These images of a Russian fighter jet
taken down by Ukrainian
the Ukrainian military,
we hear that from the Ukrainian side.
We see it on the images coming in.
We're also hearing those reports
on Russian state media
And that is significant,
of course, because what it does
show us beyond
is that the Ukrainian air
defense systems,
as much as they need
the patriot systems that are to
come online shortly
and that Ukrainian forces
are being trained on
even now,
have already seen
an extraordinary improvement in their air
defense systems.
It is several hundred
Russian plane of fighter planes
that they say they've taken down now.
And they point out
that every Russian fighter
plane on their territory
is a legitimate target.
That one
was just flying over
Donetsk region
in those occupied territory.
So those weapons
that we've been talking
about every step of the way
have come in to try and counter
exactly the next
step of the Russian offensive
when it comes to the air defense systems.
There's a lot more to do,
but this is one of the signs
that it has improved
and it is working beyond a victor.
You know, Russia's
offensive has been underway,
we're told, since early this year.
Melissa Bell and Phil Mattingly,
thank you both.
Joining us now
to discuss further,
CNN global affairs analyst Kim Doja.
She's also senior managing editor
at the Military Times.
Also with us, retired Army Brigadier
General Peter Zack.
Welcome, both of you.
Can, let me start with you
because Germany
is arguably the most important player
here, aside from the United States.
It's Europe's largest economy.
And it had been criticized
early in this war for hesitating
in providing some of the higher scale
military assistance.
Obviously, they've increased their aid
and they are sending those leopard tanks.
But now, as this war enters
its second year
and in this conversation, here
with the president of the United States,
is there
concern going into it
that Germany may remain hesitant
in the months ahead?
Well, the answer
this is a chance for the chancellor
to explain
directly to Biden
why he dragged his feet on coming up with
those leopard tanks for instance,
which meant that delayed the U.S.
announcement that it was going to send
the M1 Abrams tanks.
Germany, like Biden, in a sense,
is facing a situation
where the German people
are growing
reluctant to continue supporting this war
in that their own fears
seem to be rising.
According to recent polls,
Fears that the war could spill over
into the rest of Europe, fears
that any sort of nuclear confrontation
could literally blow into their country.
And that kind of thing.
It means that
in some senses, Schultz's hands are tied.
He's got to make
a good argument
before every single tranche of aid
he hands out.
Biden is,
in some senses facing the same thing.
And yet Biden must also be asking.
The U.S.
has given roughly two times
as much as all of Europe
combined in terms of aid to Ukraine.
He's got to be asking Germany.
What else can you ante up?
Hmm.
And what would be most crucial now?
General, as we talk about
what's happening?
But the description there is
that it is an urban style of warfare
that they are.
The Ukrainians,
they say
that they are committed to it,
but President Zelensky says
not at any cost.
I mean, what do they need?
And is part mood more of a strategic win?
Or is it something of a momentum
win, a symbolic win
for Russia and for the
victor?
But mood is important.
I would say that it is
at the tactical operational level,
important to the Ukrainian defense.
But I think for Russia and Ukraine,
this is a fight
that has really evolved
and do something is symbolic.
And if you remember,
sort of against
odds, Ukrainians held on to back, moved
through the period
of the 24 February one year anniversary.
Putin basically got no trophy win, no win
to show Moscow for that.
I think tactically, yes, it's
a lot of significance.
However,
if the Ukrainians decide
to make a tactical withdrawal,
it's not a strategic
withdrawal of the Russians
pulling back from
their son
was a strategic result withdrawal.
If they do,
they will fall back on successive
defense lines.
Yes, it'll make more
links between towns in that area,
more challenging
But it is certainly not
the end of the war in the Donbas.
So they can
but they have exacted a terrible toll
on the Russians.
But the Russians also
and in the Donbass area,
have the Russians in a bit,
excuse the metaphor of a bear hug.
So what becomes
the most important near-term
the nuts and bolts?
Artillery.
Artillery rounds, one 55 millimeter
em, 77 artillery rounds up, more stingers
which will knock down
low flying
Russian jets
that intimidate their pilots
to come in and support.
So it's a tough fight.
Ukrainians have given an amazing amount.
If they ultimately withdraw,
they have exacted their toll.
They held it through this
critical period. And
yes, it's hard to give up.
But they give they
they finally gave up Mariupol.
And and I think this will be talked
as a as a as a victory.
Well,
Ukraine also has to be mindful
of not exhausting its manpower
and its artillery as it's preparing
for its counter-offensive,
which suggests to happen
sometime in the spring.
Kim another issue
that's going to come up in
that is probably coming up
in the hours ahead in the conversation
between the president and Schultz.
And we've been talking about it
at great length here is China.
And the United States is showing
that they have intel,
that the China is seriously thinking
about providing
lethal aid
to Russia in terms of preventing that.
It's not just the United States
that can hold any leverage over China.
It's Europe as well.
And arguably Germany, its largest
trade partner.
Absolutely.
Germany needs China
for trade and vice versa.
And what the Biden administration
has always talked about
is one of their key ways
of trying to influence
China
will be to bring the allies together
in terms of market
strength and say, China,
if you want our business,
you've got to follow international norms.
So this could certainly be a way
of drilling down onto a specific
You know, China,
if you want our continuing business,
you are not going to arm
Russia in this continuing
evasion invasion.
It is also a chance to go
for the two men to talk about
those F-16s.
Just as an aside, that keeps coming up.
You know, Biden did get a chance
to have a one on one with Zelensky
where assurances would have been made,
promises likely would have been made that
no, if you give us these jets,
we won't use them to attack
Russia and escalate the war
that perhaps
is something that Biden would feel
most comfortable explaining to
one on one.